Hi, I'm John Green, this is Crash Course
Literature, and this is The Great Gatsby.
This novel barely makes it to 200 pages
even with rather large print,
and yet it's so magnificently complex and rich that
we can't possibly do it justice in two videos so
today we're gonna focus on a specific question:
Is Gatsby great?
Mr. Green! Mr. Green! No.
Oh, it's so cute when you think you're entitled
to your opinions, Me From The Past, even when
they're entirely uninformed opinions.
As penance for being such a little Hemingway
about this stuff, you will one day have to host a
show about the glorious ambiguity of literature.
[Theme Music]
So a while back we discussed the Aristotelian
tragedy of Romeo and Juliet, in which people
of high birth are brought low by weakness
of character. Shakespeare introduced some
ambiguity into that story arc as you'll remember:
There was bad luck involved in their demise,
and their mistakes, such as they were, weren't so
grievous as to render Romeo and Juliet unsympathetic.
Also, as in many tragedies, Shakespeare used
heightened, poetic language to help us care
about Romeo and Juliet and root for them instead
of just holding them up as examples of what
terrible things befall you when you're naughty.
Now obviously, Gatsby isn't a work of poetry,
but Fitzgerald found himself with similar
problems. As many a high schooler has pointed
out, the characters in The Great Gatsby aren't
terribly likeable, and the story just isn't
moving or compelling if you're reading about
a bunch of people you hate, some of whom get
what's coming to them and some of whom don't.
Fitzgerald handles this problem by heightening
the language and giving it pace. I mean, you
can basically tap your foot to The Great Gatsby
from the very first sentence: "In my younger
and more vulnerable years, my father gave me some
advice I've been turning over in my mind ever since."
It's got a beat and I can dance to it.
And the descriptions are jarringly, magnificently
beautiful, too: Daisy's voice sounds full
of money; the fading glow on Jordan Baker's
face is "like children leaving a pleasant
street at dusk." At the end of the novel,
Nick imagines the first European explorers
of New York, writing, "For a transitory, enchanted
moment, man must have held his breath in the
presence of this continent, compelled into
an aesthetic contemplation he neither understood
nor desired, face to face for the last time in history with
something commensurate to his capacity for wonder."
Putting aside the fact that Fitzgerald failed to foresee
that humans would one day walk on the moon,
not to mention create fake fake flowers the descriptions here are lush and beautiful. So the language of the novel
elevates Gatsby's triumphs and
tragedies to the stuff of real epics,
which gives Gatsby a kind of unironic greatness.
Stan! Can we just decide if these are physical
digital flowers or digital digital flowers?
Remember, you don't have to be good to be
great. And as the critic Matthew J. Bruccoli
notes, Gatsby "is truly great by virtue of
his capacity to commit himself to his aspirations."
I mean we celebrate achievement born of hard
work and clarity of purpose because there's
a greatness in that success that you don't get by, like, lounging around and using your pool all the time.
Remember, there's exactly one person at Gatsby's
parties who doesn't get drunk: Gatsby. I mean,
he's a bootlegger who doesn't drink, a swimming
pool owner who doesn't swim, a man of leisure
who never engages in a single leisure activity.
But as Bruccoli further points out, there's
plenty of irony in the titular description
of Gatsby as Great.
"The adjective indicates the tawdry and exaggerated
aspects of his life: Hurry, hurry, hurry!
Step right up and see the Great Gatsby!" I
mean, he's part magician, and- in a world
of wealth -- he's part carnival curiosity. Bruccoli
notes that Tom Buchanan describes Gatsby's
famous yellow car as "a circus wagon."
Okay let's go to the Thought Bubble. One thing
Gatsby has in common with Romeo and Juliet
is that they're all obsessed with controlling
time, which of course continues passing anyway.
Like, Juliet tries to force night to come
quickly and dawn to stay away, because only
under cover of darkness can her marriage thrive.
Similarly, Gatsby doesn't just want to marry
Daisy: He needs her to say that she never
loved Tom Buchanan at all, as if he can erase
the past 5 years. What they'll do about Daisy's
baby is a fascinating question that Gatsby
seems wholly uninterested in, but anyway,
Gatsby's dream is that he and Daisy will --
to quote Nick -- "go back to Louisville and
be married from her house -- just as if it were
five years ago."
Nick's perfectly sensible response to this
idea is, "You can't repeat the past." And
then Gatsby utters his most famous line: "Can't
repeat the past? Why of course you can."
And then he says, "I'm going to fix everything
just the way it was before." Romeo and Juliet
want to extend the present into forever because
they know their future is bleak; Gatsby believes
the key to the beautiful future is a perfect restoration
of the beautiful past. Thanks, Thought Bubble
Okay, a brief aside before we return to Gatsby's
questionably greatness: The idea of restoring
the past to create a beautiful future is or
course, not unique to Gatsby, which is why
no candidate for President can ever get through a
speech without mentioning some previous President,
whose glorious leadership the current campaign intends to channel so as to make it morning in America again.
It's also why Americans fight so much about
what the Founding Fathers would think of us,
when in fact, what they would think is probably
"You guys are dressed funny. Also, how come
this room is so bright without any windows?
Furthermore, why is this screen talking to me?"
Now of course this nostalgia isn't unique to the
United States, but you also have to remember
that Gatsby is the ultimate self-made man, having
both literally and figuratively made a name for himself.
And this combination of aspirational impulses
and the urge to restore life to some immaculate
past does strike me as very American. That's
what makes the tragedy of Gatsby so much more
interesting and complicated than the Aristotelian
model of tragedy.
Instead of being a person of high birth, Gatsby
is a person of low birth, albeit one born
into a world that claims not to care
about or even believe in such things.
And instead of experiencing a reversal of fortune
due to a weakness of character, Jay Gatsby -- well
that's were it gets complicated actually.
I mean Daisy Buchanan was driving the car,
but Gatsby chose to take the fall for her.
But he is also doomed because he lives in
a social order that's happy to drink illegal
alcohol, but condemns a sober bootlegger.
Oh, it's time for the Open Letter?
An Open Letter to Prohibition. But first let's
see what is the secret compartment today.
Be booze, be booze, be booze. Yes! Touchdown.
It's mystery liquor.
Alright the game is simple, I drink the mystery
liquor and try to guess what it is. [coughs]
Southern Comfort?... No? What is it? Jack
-- that's too easy, Meredith. Jack Daniels.
Anybody could get Jack Daniels.
Dear Prohibition,
You were crazy. I mean, for the rest of American
history, our Constitution is gonna be this
weird document that is perfectly normal until
the 18th Amendment, which suddenly bans alcohol,
and then the 21st Amendment which is suddenly
like, "No, no, no. Terrible idea!" It's almost like
legislating morality doesn't actually increase morality.
But Prohibition, in you, Fitzgerald found
the perfect metaphor for American hypocrisy
and debauchery. We are not very good at tolerating
naughtiness in America, but we love being
naughty. In short Prohibition, you were a terrible
idea, but a fantastic metaphor, so thanks for that.
Best Wishes, [coughs]
John Green.
So is Gatsby doomed by his romanticization
of Daisy, by his refusal to accept that he
just wasn't born to be one of the gold-hatted
men of leisure, by his belief that any means
justifies -- if you'll pardon the pun -- Daisy's
end?
Yes, yes, and yes. But more than that, the
great Gatsby lives in a cold world that cares
nothing for justice, a world that makes claims
to fairness but really only further rewards
those who have already been rewarded.
I mean, who even survives this novel? Only
the idle rich: Jordan Baker, Daisy and Tom
Buchanan, Nick Carraway. They survive, and
they are allowed to go on being careless.
As Nick writes, "They were careless people,
Tom and Daisy -- they smashed up things and
creatures and then retreated back into their
money or their vast carelessness."
They aren't cruel or malicious, they're just
careless -- they don't care too much about
Myrtle or Gatsby or their daughter or even
each other. To live without a care in the
world is supposed to be the dream, right?
Everyone wants a care-free life. But Fitzgerald
shows us the horror of this care-free life,
how Tom and Daisy's inability to care is in
some ways more monstrous than outright cruelty
would be.
It's not like Romeo and Juliet, where the
lovers are sacrificed and then Verona is healed.
Nothing is made whole by the tragedy of The
Great Gatsby.
I think that's why some readers find the
novel depressing and hopeless, even amid all
the lush language and witty turns of phrase.
But I don't think it is hopeless. Remember
that line from the first chapter: "Gatsby
turned out all right in the end, it was what
preyed on Gatsby, what foul dust floated in
the wake of his dreams..." As individuals,
and as a collective, the tragedy isn't in
dreaming; it's in chasing an unworthy dream.
So in the end, is Gatsby great? I'm interested
to read your comments, but here's my takeaway:
Jay Gatsby was a great man. But great people
especially must be careful about what they worship.
Thanks for watching. I'll see you
next week.
Crash Course is produced and directed by Stan
Muller. Too far! Our script supervisor is
Meredith Danko. The associate producer is
Danica Johnson. The show is written by me.
And our graphics team is Thought Bubble. Every
week, instead of cursing, I say the name of
a writer I like if you'd like to suggest writers.
you can do so in comments where you can also
ask questions about today;s video that will
be answered by our team of English Literature
experts. Thanks for watching Crash Course
and as we say in my hometown,
Don't Forget To Be Awesome.